So far we've set up our own service
worker, learned its life cycle, and
explored the dev tools, but
we haven't really used our service
worker to do anything yet.
Currently, the server's having all
the fun when it comes to sending content
back to the browser.
Well, now it's our turn to have fun.
So far we've seen requests go from the
page, through the service worker fetch
event, then onto the network as usual,
through the HTTP cache.
But now we're going to catch the request
as it hits the service worker, and
respond ourselves, so
nothing goes to the network.
Obviously, this is an important
step in going offline first, so
let's make it happen.
Over in the service worker script,
we can call event.respondWith.
This tells the browser that we're
going to handle this request ourselves.
Event or
respondWith takes a response object or
a promise that resolves with a response.
One way to create a response is well,
new response.
The first parameter is the body of
the response, which can be a blob,
a buffer, some other things, but
at its simplest it can take a string.
So here I'm going to
respond with Hello world.
Back in the browser, because I have
Force update on reload checked,
I refresh once, and
I get the custom response.
No matter what URL I enter here,
I get the same response,
because I'm intercepting all fetches.
I could even modify the response
to include some HTML.
Back in the page, I hit refresh, and
although the HTML is there,
it's just being output as text.
You can see why if you
look in the network panel.
The content type is text/plain,
meaning it won't be passed as HTML.
Thankfully, I can set headers
as part of the response.
The second parameter of
new request is an object.
And the header's property takes
an object of headers and values.
So I can set the foo header to be bar.
Back in the page, hit refresh, and
in the network panel, there it is.
The phone lines have lit up and
that can only mean one thing.
A wild Mike Wales has appeared.
Hello, Mike.
>> Hey, fixing that request sounds
like something the student can do.
>> Fair point, go for it.